alex rodriguez says he was surprised by
jennifer lopez reuniting with her
ex-fiance ben
affleck it's really hard a source tells
e.t
quote alex understands that jennifer is
single but felt
shocked by their quick meet-up at the
end of the day alex wants
jennifer to be happy but the way
everything has unfolded
doesn't sit well with him i i have no
explanation for that
the source adds a-rod and j-lo have
remained in contact after breaking off
their engagement in april
and plan to remain friends and in
business together
if you remember the exes met up for
dinner not long after
calling it quits i'm just taking it one
day at a time
the source adds people close to alex do
feel things
might be different if jennifer's
relationship with ben develops more as
it's all happened so quick
jennifer usually remains close to her
exes and she plans to do the same with
alex
just gonna try to enjoy every minute
stay present jennifer has been spending
lots of time with ben
most recently jetting off to montana
together it feels really good and it's
really nice
according to multiple sources the pair
was alone vacationing at the yellowstone
club in montana for a week
i think we had chemistry as actors from
the first moment we started working
but how does alex feel about their
week-long getaway
in a clip published by page six the
former baseball player
only had two words go yankees i love to
compete i love to win
although he dodged the question it's
worth pointing out that alex
formally played for the new york yankees
a major rival to
you guessed it ben's favorite team the
boston red sox
i don't know how that happened and seems
like ben is not letting go of jen
this time in may a source told et that
ben has always had an affinity for
jennifer
and was the one who initially started
pursuing her and making an effort to
reconnect romantically speaking
quote he wanted to explore things with
her beyond a friendship
and they've both really been enjoying
spending time together
you